we've already talked about the aztec
civilization in several videos but what
we're going to focus on in this video is
the aztec empire which shouldn't be
confused with the aztec civilization the
civilization is referring to the broader
groups of people over hundreds of years
but the aztec empire is a very specific
entity that formed in the hundred years
before spanish colonization
what you see here is a zoomed in version
of what today would be southern mexico
and right over here on the globe and you
can see many city-states formed here a
city-state is a city that is also
considers itself a state that has its
own political organization its own way
of functioning it's not dependent on any
other government forms and it's
analogous to what we see in classical
greece where you have the city-states of
athens and sparta
now what's particularly interesting is
what's going on around lake texacoco
in the 14th century
in
1325 you have the city of tenochtitlan
form on this island in lake texcoco
and initially tenochtitlan is one of the
weaker city-states around lake texcoco
you see many of these city-states some
of the stronger ones you have texcoco
right here and in particular you have
ascapotsalco but as we fast forward
roughly 100 years you get to a situation
where askapotzalco falls into a civil
war
their ruler dies and there's a
succession battle and the various
city-states around lake texcoco take
sides what eventually happens is tenosh
chitlan
tex koko
and tslakopan
form what is known as a triple alliance
or the triple alliance and are able to
conquer the ascap podzalko
and so in conquering the ascopodzalco
what you have forming is known as the
aztec
empire
now it starts as an alliance between
these three city-states and other
city-states in the area but over time
tenochtitlan which is sometimes referred
to as mexico tenochtitlan because it is
a city-state of the mexico people and
this is where the name mexico or mexico
actually comes from now even though it's
an alliance
over time tenoshtitlan essentially
becomes the capital of this alliance or
the capital of this aztec empire which
continues on for roughly 100 years until
when it is defeated by hernando cortes
now the story of how hernando cortes is
able to conquer this empire is
fascinating and i'm not going to be able
to go into all of the details in this
video but needless to say he's able to
convince several hundred conquistadors
to come and try to conquer the empire
and he's able to do so by recruiting
tens of thousands some estimates i've
seen are a hundred thousand soldiers
from neighboring city-states who had
issues with the mexico or with the aztec
empire and so he's eventually able to
take over the famed city of tenochtitlan
it's really important to recognize how
advanced they were at the time you see
these causeways these bridges leading
into the island they had a fairly
advanced dam system to collect fresh
water from the rain while also to
control flooding in fact a lot of that
was destroyed when the conquistadors
came and mexico city which eventually
gets founded over this lake is going to
have issues with flooding for some time
in the future in fact the spanish in
order to control the flooding end up
draining this lake and is where mexico
city forms
but the big takeaway here is near the
end of the aztec civilization as we get
to the hundred years before the
conquistadors arrive
you have this empire form this empire
which starts as an alliance of
city-states but eventually becomes a
tributary empire unlike the neighboring
mayans which were on the yucatan
peninsula on this map they would be in
this region right over here the
neighboring mayans were autonomous
city-states some might have had more
power more influence at different times
but the aztec tributary state means the
other city states are paying tribute to
tenochtitlan they are paying revenue
they are paying service to what
essentially is the capital or the seat
of that empire until it is conquered by
the spanish with and remember the
spanish are able to do this with several
hundred conquistadors with the help of
neighboring city-states and a smallpox
epidemic which kills 50 percent of the
population of the region